there is no live video today I know I
know I'm sorry but actually right now
I'm in New York I'm over the other side
of the pond and you know it's very
difficult to go live when you're I think
I'm not the Rockefeller right now okay
but instead I've put together a little
bit of a compilation for you with some
funny bits and some silly bits and some
educational bits from the last 12 months
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so before we get into the video I just
wanted to say that there's been a really
brilliant 12 months
um this time last year we had 5 000
subscribers we now have pushing 15
000 subscribers
um at the start of the year we had no
idea what was going on with Stargate
which is one of our favorite shows but
now thanks to Sidetrack and the sources
I speak to we've got a really good idea
what's going on and we're just waiting
for that final announcement it has been
a little bit of a roller coaster but
we're at the Finishing Line
also I just wanted to thank the people
that behind the scenes help Sidetrack uh
Matt Dean joined the channel this year
he now does a video on a Tuesday he does
a lot of the technical stuff because I
don't know how computers work
I wanted to thank stormy who comes on
every single week even though he is
insanely busy building spaceships but he
really gives his time because he loves
the content he gets really nothing out
of it other than the enjoyment of
talking to him this stupid idiot and you
know I just thank him so much he is our
resident American he always will be he
is Danny Gandalf and we love him dearly
we got joined this year as well by a
young good-looking American now Harris
is too good looking we don't like him
because of that his hair's too long and
he's got too much of it we don't like
him because of that but it comes with
such Brilliant Energy and really amazing
insights and a completely different
point of view to me and stormy really
and that again he gets nothing out of it
other than the enjoyment of come and
talking to us so again Harris thank you
so much sir we're really really looking
forward to 2023 the year that we will
finally get Stargate back on our screens
hopefully and bye guys thank you so much
for subscribing for liking every video
for sharing videos
I just really really have loved the last
12 months and just thank you very much
but hey that's enough soccer [ __ ] get on
with the video
hello and we are live welcome to
Sidetrack all you lovely side trackers
and welcome to stormy my resident
American hello hello hello stormy how
are you mate
I'm not in Ukraine so I'm doing quite
well we're all nuts in Ukraine so we're
all doing better than the ukrainians
um
and we won't talk politics because
that's not what we do here but
world war three
that's a distinct possibility what's
your favorite World War III film
so one thing about Barbarella is when at
the time one of the world's foremost
mimes Marcel Marceau he was uh he played
Professor ping
did he say anything
bad guys walking in the wind he's
walking in the wind yeah minds are evil
we should probably kill all the mimes
welcome to Sidetrack we are a little
late and stormy seems to have fallen off
his chair but we had some technical
issues with the volume and now our
General on board the storm is falling
off his chair because you were there a
second ago storm oh I had to take
were
CGI rendered on an LCD screen that the
actor was in front of
that blew me away these artists now use
the Quake
graphic system they make all of these
detailed scenes
complete total scenes
floor backs of the back and in the
ceiling and they call it the volume and
then the actor goes in this and they're
completely wrapped around
I didn't know that I didn't know that
was a thing that's incredible yes and
and when I
saw you know
I was worried No this was good this is
good it's good and I see all the scenes
and I'm like wow that's pretty good
special facts but no the the actual
visual that's on the LCD screen behind
the actor
um and so now you know those whole
companies that build these uh these uh
environments that you can just download
into your Quake system and render it in
this volume What's called the volume the
studio normally in effect will be
anything you see out of a window is sort
of like they used to these giant photos
didn't they all paintings and they'd be
incredibly detailed it cost hundreds of
thousands of pounds these things to
produce
um it's it's kind of like obviously you
can have a set everything in the
foreground as a set but then everything
in a distance that's sort of like that
one ecstasy that's sort of like taking
that sort of thing it's just completely
they went Coast in the digital world but
in a physical way which allows them to
react to it though then yeah yeah I'll
send you some links of the technology it
will just make your jaw drop it's insane
it is just
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and I
was looking at myself and I forgot to
look at the camera
very professional as always a Robocop
sequel if it's like the last RoboCop
movie
I I will punch myself in my private
parts before I watch it it was awful the
actor that they have to play RoboCop
doesn't have to be anybody famous
even when Wella did it back in the day
they had to have a bit where his helmet
came off and he saw his face because
he's the actor so you've got to see his
face the last guy that did it was really
good in Hannah but he was crapping
Robocop and again they had to show his
face for loads of periods of time
because he's probably in his contract
RoboCop has gonna think he's a very
specific character and that film really
is something I was really really looking
forward to and it was terrible
if they do do a sequel I said doo doo
then it should needs to be a hard reboot
for me just forget that that terrible
movie Michael Keaton was great in it to
be fair but forget that RoboCop movie
happened and just do a better version
I'd like to even see a sequel from the
original you know RoboCop 2 sort of
thing
Matthew don't panic calm down you're
okay
um
I bought
it like we'll put it this way if
everybody out of a team of 20 people
loved the script and thought it was the
way to go you'd be concerned because
someone's lying
somebody in that group is not going to
like it or think that that maybe they
should try something else or fresh blood
or whatever there'll be probably people
in that room that maybe just don't like
Brad I don't know it's this this is
these are human beings we're talking
about it's going to be happening
the worry comes though is we need to
find out who those people are because at
the end of the day if it's like Steve
Wright is you know the chief's executive
at MGM who does just got these concerns
then there's a problem because he's the
guy that's going to be making that final
decision
so I'm not surprised really that there
are voices I'm surprised
that they're still talking about it
because it seemed to me about two or
three weeks ago the Brad rice project
was the one they were going to go with
when they scrapped the other one when
they were doing preliminary artwork and
stuff for
um presentations to present to the
executives during these meetings for
this second mysterious script where they
scrapped it about three weeks ago I
thought well that's it then Brad's
writes projects in that's done it's the
only one they're talking about
they've looked at some of the artwork
and they've looked at the script and
they've had conversations about it and
they're still talking about whether they
think it's the right way to go or not
now
that is a concern because
doubts very concerned once a project is
black and white and running then you
know you can everyone can get behind it
I was really confident two weeks ago
that this is going to happen I'm going
to happen really fast I was thinking you
know July
do we know when the 25th anniversary
happens we can actually get this green
lit we could we could start really
getting some really serious information
now
it doesn't seem
that it's a certain
I actually think that this this Summit
and when the bosses have got involved
and they've kicked This Plane around
might have put Stargate back six months
to me it seems to me that they're asking
questions
but then the team is gonna have to go
back and answer
they're going to have to go back maybe
even to Brad Wright and start having
conversations and that basically means
this is all
starting that process again where we
were at a point where we were I mean Joe
milosi said that though we were five
Chevrons encoded but he said but the
sixth the seventh steps are the hardest
ones the sixth and seventh steps are the
ones to where the bosses get involved
and the chief Executives get involved
and they start having to do pitch
meetings and somebody has to actually
write a damn check
now it seemed to me that a lot of the
work for the sixth Chevron has been done
over the last two months or so
preliminary artwork a little bit of
storyboarding but when I say
storyboarding it's very preliminary it's
just stuff to like show the executives
in Pitch meetings it's nothing that
would be ever used for actual proper
storyboarding in pre-production
um
but all that stuff does you know
convince the executives that yes let's
do this all that work seems to have been
done
if after these meetings they do decide
you know what we don't like it it's back
to square one
initially 12 months ago they were hoping
to have Stargate with our screens by
them summer next year
um
in a very short video I was on the
holidays
that Michael Deluca and Pam Abdi who are
the uh the chairman of the motion
pictures for MGM and the motion picture
group president basically the two top
people for MGM uh Motion Pictures in
particular but they really are the top
two Executives have resigned
but they didn't really as much resign as
um get pushed out
the Mike Hopkins who is a big executive
for Amazon released a statement not long
afterwards saying that basically their
departure has paved the way for MGM to
be merged and to become a part of
um Amazon and Amazon pictures
now this has royally annoyed MGM
employees that I speak to because
they've been telling me for a long long
time now
um that actually Amazon had been making
lots and lots of promises they've been
promising that there would be no job
losses that there would be
um an element of Independence stayed
within within MGM the mgme would be able
to continue to make its own business
arrangements and continue to do projects
that it wants to do but basically Amazon
was just going to act like a parent
company and they weren't going to
interfere too much of what MGM wanted to
do
there was repeated memos apparently sent
around MGM from these Executives
actually from
Michael Deluca and Pam Aberdeen telling
the MGM employees that Amazon just
wanted them to carry on doing their good
work the MGM was the home of some of the
world's greatest storytellers and that's
what Amazon were buying that they were
not going to start thinking about this
wow great special facts this has great
sound this has great music and then I
was like we know there are a lot of
really great movies that had none of
that
fantasy whatever genre so what was it
you know and um in college I did a paper
on Hitchcock you know Hitchcock was
really good with the tools of the time
you know but his his
um
his real talent was not overdoing it
yeah I mean you know he had access to
everything but he just didn't overdo it
and so
I mean there's lots of things he could
have done with the birds with psycho the
tools that were out there he just never
used because
he was always trying to push the story
forward yeah and I think at the very end
of the day uh it's the story that is is
the centerpiece there's a there's a book
I think it's actually titled story uh
that if you work for Pixar when you go
to work for Pixar you have to read the
book I think that even the receptionist
has to read the book title story about
storytelling and how you tell a story
properly
good evening hello and welcome to
Sidetrack and sorry about my background
it's going all crazy and blurry but I
can't get the light tonight so excited
I am going live this evening as a lot of
you know already
because last night while I was sleeping
snoring my head off my wife so the
questions oh yeah
which is avionics an aviation background
I think it's fair to say yes right so
yeah and you understand space travel and
things and you have a little bit of
understanding of that area as well
um
so
in
I'm just gonna say what in sci-fi do you
think of the series that have actually
done really well with designing ships
and things that are
pretty accurate or pretty
um
um that's what I'm looking for
obeys the laws of physics realism you
know that's a bit of realism to them a
base laws of physics actually if you're
going to build a Starship it's what it
would be like
um or could be and what the series that
you just think no why why do the shoes
look like that and I'll throw in the Hat
straight away
Star Trek there is absolutely no reason
why all the stars the Federation
Starships look like that
I know they say it's to do with like
warp and stuff but a boy
it doesn't bother it and so why do all
the Starships look all that that pretty
when it doesn't make any sense at all
um but I just wondered if you had any
thoughts about what series does anything
jump to mind you think
actually that that that is that does
make sense and I haven't asked you about
this before and so I'm completely thrown
in the Deep I'm sorry but
uh well the the probably the best
um
that really does work hard to get it
right is the expanse
the um when they were when when the
script is written
the type of of uh the
colors of the paper they use
shows the type of gravity that they're
in
you know is it high gravity is it on
Earth is it on a station you know it
actually was it weightless I mean they
they go to the so far
to get it right is they color code the
pages depending on what kind of gravity
the actors are allegedly supposed uh
exposed
[Music]
good afternoon good morning good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and welcome to Sidetrack on sci-fi
Sunday your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
oh someone's defeated I I had to shut up
I had an open tab that went and why
got Americans you can't trust them to do
we're in a different time John welcome
to Scientific Sci-Fi TV yes our Movie
Channel and we are going to have we have
a rant but I'll introduce you in a
second shut up Matthew wait your turn
I'm gonna have a bit of a rant tonight
in this Star Gate related so we'll get
into it in a second and no shock if
you've been watching the news it's going
to be giant freaking robot
Matt how are you sir you're allowed to
speak now I'm good I'm good how are you
but like yeah they're a bit they're
they're similar style and stuff and yeah
that fast case brilliant as well so all
right cool we picked it shadows and four
movies we've obviously got aliens the
xenomorph which I suggested we got siren
on the end that way and we've got
whatever Harris said which I've now
forgotten what you said that on that one
as well God me will forget
AKA t1000. haven't you you were talking
foreign
right
how about the second one I'd be that'd
be interesting to see what people would
rate a chance I haven't given it a
chance so I keep saying it's terrible
and I don't know because I've only
watched half an hour of the first one I
need to give it a chance so my opinion
really is irrelevant on that what was
that was it uh
Genie
I had about 45 minutes of the dwarf
singing and I got bored and turned it
off
because that's what Builder wagon takes
so carefully
thanks soon for so long though come on
it was just went on and on I I went and
built a shed came back and they were
still singing that's how we're going are
you sure you weren't like Martin
Freeman's double during that time period
because I I think that's exactly like
that was like his that was the scene
right there
hmm
yeah you know and of course wait till
you get the king to the king of Goblin
Town
okay that sounds like fun he has a bit
of addition to say my Lodge has watched
all three and he says I'm being an idiot
and I should watch them because
sorry we all know that's true
yeah
it wasn't even me
Gandolf Davido strikes again
that's right I'm getting my hat hang on
uh we'll be back in a minute and then
Disney they've got Willow and it's gonna
blow both of these shows out the water I
cannot wait for Willow it's gonna be
awesome I'm very glad you finished that
with both of these out of the water I
thought you were about to say Willow was
gonna blow and I was just about to just
hang my head instead I'm still excited
[Music]
that's the next t-shirt design I'm doing
and again
borderline stupid but this would you
Matt I've not seen the film be scared of
a human being coming at you if he had
tiny little wings on his feet they may
let him fly or would you just go
is that and laugh at him what like
Apollo
yeah like um Hermes Hermes no excuse me
we're the same it's stupid love it it's
very good you're a bit of it it's you
like rom-coms Matt by any chance I love
rom-coms I don't know why I'm saying
that like it's a bad thing all right you
put Sandra Bullock and Hugh Grant in a
movie and I am one happy little camper
not actually it's fantastic
uh one of my favorite films of all time
is um two weeks notice the subject can
you guys I watch anytime I'm so happy
that was a good film yeah yeah
quickly best rom-com you're your
favorite rom-com ever two weeks is that
really I'm not the biggest fan but the
proposal is just too good for me I love
that one I'll tell you actually
Carrie Grant
um Father Goose
is the best rom-com ever made it's a
it's an absolute classic and it's an
absolute classic that's never really
been remade
um which is
unheard of you know you think so you're
calling for the Remake now
oh God probably please don't because it
needs to be carried around but a few
things think think of things like
Serendipity there that's actually a film
that's just been remade over and over
again you know it's like um uh I can't
remember but that was actually a classic
um a Cary Grant movie from back in the
day um was it indiscretion
I forget but uh it's just the same films
were made over and over again
um I think people would have been
pressed on it every time but then they
all you know the movie because they
always end up the Empire State Building
at the end
certainly just do a slight Different
Twist on it
um Tom Hanks did one with um they're
growing
uh before we did You've got mail the
other one Sleepless in Seattle
um but yeah well go if you ever
Father Goose Carrie Grant if it's an old
movie but you love it it's great yeah
father
um one of the things I loved about I'll
tell you what I mean in the 80s I'd love
to do a video one of the days and just
do talk about some of the movies in the
80s because God it was a terrible decade
fashion and music and oh God it was
awful
um
aren't they from your neck of the word
sir oh no no but I tell you what some of
the greatest movies ever been a little
bit idle what's wrong with you
Cindy Whopper
are you afraid of this you didn't need a
Whopper
I'm a rock fan
ever came out in the 80s stop rock music
in the 80s was embarrassing the the the
one of the best albums of the decade
uh talking here
that was a great okay
all of a sudden
they're always I just love the fact that
stormy was excited about Sydney Lopper
it's all in the concert she was a maze
boss she was I that's I bet I love it
and at my cousins uh do it and um
my uh my uh my cousin Tony stuck with me
my cousin Andrea she went off and
somehow got on the front row and just it
was a festival seating
and she just came back and just was
transformed oh my God Cindy I loved her
hair
oh
yeah
[ __ ] you the late families were the best
and then all the different points
iterations
um so I take that back parts of the age
clearly speaking it was God awful
um but I mean some of the greatest
movies generally some of the greatest
movies was the predator in the 80s or
was it
um
lady mid 80s
I'm gonna google it you know War Games
80s Lost Boys Beetlejuice Legends the
first Batman
Breakfast Club Flash Dance
Commander oh yeah that was so sad Irene
Carey died the first June in her 60s
sure good come on Batman
I kind of just point out this comment
because I guys just put a comment in the
video and it's generally made me laugh
in my brain because I've never thought
about it before but
stormy you do look a bit like Danny
DeVito
that's never occurred to me but yeah a
little bit
okay so cast and read Because I will
read that all um um of these I just
think what we should do is get the
Muppets together and just remake every
TV show that's on TV now but with the
Muppets so how's the dragon Muppets
uh Lord of the Rings not pits everything
the boys with Muppets Jesus Christ
please all the boys with Muppets I'm
talking about Amazon a whole new project
for him those two just come on
500 million dollars on those two
projects right a behind the scenes thing
where there's also the executive with
all the executives the thing is it might
be a bit too realistic a bit too close
to the Bone
um but yeah
do I need to see Miss Piggy shouting son
every third or four you can't say that
I'm sorry
for the trouble by the morning
sorry
Jesus Christ thank you I am so sorry
that is the one word you cannot say not
the UK well part of us we might we might
have some leeway no it's the one word
YouTube really don't like you stop
I was quoting a show I was quoting a
character
it's uttered by Carl eubane over over
and over and over and over and over I
can spell it out let me get something no
see you next Tuesday is the only way you
can say it on my channel
do I need to see
there goes the monetization
[Music]